STUDENT: I'm Matt Susskind.
And for this game, we are a
team of eight people working
on forecast-based financing,
which is a technique using
forecasts in order
to make decisions
about what to do in response
to incoming disasters.
Currently, a lot
of techniques are
we're going to build long-term
protection for cities
in terms of dams or
disaster preparedness.
Or, after disaster happens,
we will react to the disaster.
But there's not a lot of
work done in terms of we
see that there is a
50% chance of disaster
within the next week.
Let's start mobilizing
to prepare for that.
And part of the
reason for that is
because if the
disaster doesn't happen
you end up wasting money.
But if you actually
do an analysis,
you'll realize that the
money that you waste
is actually way less
expensive than trying
to make up for your lack of
preparedness after the fact.
So Paolo had come in from the
Red Cross Red Crescent Climate
Center.
And he pitched a couple
of different concepts
that they wanted
games around in order
to educate either members
of the Red Cross or people
out in the world who
they wanted to show
these different ideas to.
And so what he showed us was
actually just a PowerPoint
with a couple of different
slides, where on each slide
was a different concept.
Ours was forecast-based
financing.
But then, there were also
ones like cholera, or Ebola,
or preparing for heat
waves, things like that.
And so he gave us a
quick pitch of this
is what the concept is, this
is who we want to educate
with this, and these are
some of the characteristics
that we think are
really important.
And we actually weren't
assigned to any topics.
He put those topics
up on the board
and let teams form
around them, depending
on what you're interested in.
And so beyond just
the idea of this
is forecast-based financing,
and this is how it works
and who we want to teach it to,
we got no further instructions.
Paolo did come in
throughout the class
to teach us a little
bit more about who
we would be talking to,
or to work over the ideas
that we had been exploring.
But on the whole, we just
got the general topic,
and came up with the
game ideas on our own.
One of our biggest
challenges was
with forecast-based financing,
it's an understandable topic,
but it's sort of abstract.
And it doesn't quite
lend itself to a game.
It's very easy to
come up with we're
going to take
forecast-based financing
and hide it as a game.
But that's not a
fun game to play.
So a lot of our
challenge is figuring out
how are we going to work?
How are we going
to create a game
around forecast-based financing
that explains the ideas that we
want, that teaches
people something new,
and is a game that
we're actually proud of?
Another compounding factor
was that originally our target
audience was policymakers, which
was a very difficult audience,
because they don't generally
play games, which meant that we
were starting with
trying to teach them
everything from scratch.
Whereas when you're
creating for somebody
who has experience
with video games,
you can take a lot of
things for granted--
that they're going to
know how to drag and drop
things in order
to change things,
or what the various design
ideas you're using actually
mean to them.
So that was a big
challenge for us,
was designing for
this new consumer.
And we also had a lot
of design challenges
with getting the forecast-based
financing game to work.
And the way that we
approached it at first
was by creating a whole bunch
of different prototypes of lot
of different types of games,
and trying them out with people,
seeing what they understood,
what they liked about them,
what didn't work, what they
learned from them, which
was really good in terms of
exploring different ideas
and learning more
about the subject area.
But it created a new
difficulty in that
we were all over the
place for the first couple
weeks of the project.
We got to the
point about halfway
through-- we had about eight
weeks to do this project,
I think, and halfway
through, we still
didn't end up with
our final idea yet.
Instead, we were exploring
all these different ideas,
and pulling in various parts of
them in order to make our game.
And then, we realized that our
game lacked a coherent vision.
We had been working on
a couple prototypes.
We didn't like any of them.
It didn't feel like players
had a connection to them,
both in terms of what was
happening in the game,
but also a mental
connection of I
understand exactly
what's happening here.
So we decided to take
everything we had learned
and some of the
systems we had built,
and package them
into a new UI, which
was this side view of the rising
water, which everybody just
understood intuitively.
You see a village.
You see someone standing there.
You see the water
rising toward it.
And it doesn't
matter who you are.
You understand that this is
something that's in danger.
And you're going to
need to do something
about the rising waters.
And once we hit on that idea,
everything became much easier.
Of course, there were still
ideas we had to explain,
concepts we had to
design into the game
in an understandable way.
But for the most part, the
game was actually there.
The mechanics themselves
didn't change very much
between the prototype we
had before and this idea
of the rising waters.
But just packaging
it in a new design
changed the game, the
feel of it, completely.
So I had game design
experience beforehand.
So I like game design a lot.
I was hoping to
work more on that.
But also to get some
interesting games made.
I think I did get some of that.
But probably the thing
I learned the most
that I didn't expect
coming in was just how
to work with a team.
We're all busy MIT students.
And so we would have weeks
where all of a sudden, everybody
would have a test.
And we had no time
to do anything else.
And so it was a
lot of learning how
to work with people
who are extremely busy
and who have a lot
on their plate.
And so it's really easy
for things to slip,
for things to get forgotten,
fall through the cracks.
So it taught me a lot about
project management, basically,
and solving problems
as a team, and learning
how to get everybody-- I don't
want to say herding cats,
because it's not like
people didn't care.
But it's just that
we were so busy.
It taught me how to work
with these busy people
to get to where we need to be.